hello everyone i'm alana and welcome i
had some internet issues this morning
also i'm in australia so it was at 3am
that basically meant that i missed ea
play live
i have intentionally stayed off of
social media for the last 16 hours
apparently it was when this was live
so i've not had any spoilers and i
thought that i would just hang out watch
it with you guys anyway catch up for
anyone on different time zones who it
also happened to be in the middle of the
night for
um so let's start the stream
i what would i hope for i think they
said we're not gonna see skate
um i would take titanfall i would also
always take more apex news obviously
they're going to talk about fifa
um though i never find that terribly
interesting um
what else what uh dragon age would be
cool
um austin reminded me the other day that
there is a new mass effect in
development i'd be curious to see that
i look i'd love to see dead space that
would be really nice ea if that could
happen would be really cool
um what else do ea have that i like
i always like seeing like new sims
expansions and dlcs like i always find
that to be quite fun
um even if i don't generally play them
sometimes they they get really
interesting collaborations like the
stuff that they did with um
star wars etc was neat to see i'm trying
to think of what
what else ea has oh the originals
program
uh i did a stream of the
originals ea play live spotlight the
other day and
um there were a couple of studios that
had currently unannounced games
i would love to see more of those i
think the originals program is very cool
um you know i've spent a lot of time
being very critical of ea on the
internet across multiple platforms
often cases i think it's quite well
deserved um
but they also do things that i like so i
like to talk about the things that i
like
in between being heavily critical i'm
super into battlefield
um franchise that i really really enjoy
i hope that bioware can go back to what
i consider
bioware former glory that would be
amazing
um so yeah there are definitely things
that i like eea originals program is one
of them which is where
games like i think it's called fey and
it takes two and unravel came from
all of that good stuff oh fallen order
two would be interesting as well
yeah i strongly believe that that game
is in development
um
i've heard rumors also of kotor
iii that
like industry inside rumors of of that
being written so i'm pretty sure that
that's also in development um
but maybe that's changed and is out of
date by this point i don't know
but uh yeah
this is live alphacat welcome we are
watching this live right now
all right 10 seconds let's do it
what do they start with fifa they
already did a madden conference didn't
they or am i misremembering that
it could be i'm not sure
great
okay
am i watching the right thing um did i
make a weird mistake
did i click on the wrong link
oh my god i did not think that this is
how
this conference would start what
okay ea okay
oh my gosh probably my favorite way to
open a show
ever oh this is a pre-show
okay i guess we could jump ahead
i just don't want to spoil anything for
myself what's the problem but what if
they have stuff that i'm interested in
they might i don't know i'm scared to
look at the chat because i'm worried you
guys are going to spoil things for me
don't need to listen to any of this okay
i personally have that
find this countdown don't spoil anything
count down on the right way
okay wait is this too far ahead huge
summary
no come on
come on i'm so scared of going too far
it's about here it's gonna be it's gonna
be right here okay let's go
this is the beginning of the conference
i really like this graphic i've been
seeing it all over the internet i really
like what they
what they did with that very neat
did i miss anything in that pre-show
anybody
might be okay no it's austin
um all right turn it up a bit i'm your
host wwe superstar xavier woods aka
austin creed and we have an amazing show
he's such a nice guy
just as nice as he seems online he's
awesome
including a brand new except when you
play among us with them then it gets
nasty
and a few more surprises
plus just like last year we've got some
amazing prizes to give away
so keep an eye out i forgot that they
did that last year
with greg miller number one voice actor
if you want a chance to win polaris gear
logitech gadgets and thousands of codes
for great ea games
including mass effect legendary edition
dirt 5 and
more so let's get to it
all right okay that's pretty cool was
need for speed
okay austin he's like he's a great host
this is a good call
it's i'm i'm beginning to think it's not
need for speed
fan favorite yeah titles from need for
speed to burnout to real racing
and now that the experts at codemasters
codemasters are very good family
that incredible lineup just got super
charged with the addition of franchises
like grid
dirt project cars and f1 i've done
interviews for a lot of these games um
talking to them about project cars
specifically
fascinating so much detail
there's no way that i don't get
copyright strike for this stream too
thanks ea grid's really fun
i'm really loud i mean it looks like
it's loud but okay it's a little bit
louder
i'm a little bit quieter there you go
[Music]
oh
i always look at um
[Music]
racing games as a test for
graphics realism
that's pretty good hang on let me make
sure that we're actually in 1080p
we are mostly i'm like it looks okay the
video games look okay
great is really fun you should flavor it
it was exciting london is code masters
senior game designer
becky crossdale welcome becky hi austin
hey now i heard that you might have a
little surprise for us today
yes i do and i don't know if you can
tell austin but i am so
excited because on behalf of the entire
codemasters team
this is the world premiere trailer for
grid legends cool
hmm
what does it mean why is it live action
see when you do it this way you can tell
which part's a video game very clearly
my goal is to become the first woman
ever to win the championship oh my god
you're the coolest person i've ever
[ __ ] seen in my life
series world champion does yumi have an
instagram
that's a new record what the heck
if it's grid legal i can build it to win
touring cars muscle cars open wheel
drift
i'm assuming that i don't know enough
about the racing industry that these
aren't
real people these are characters but i
don't know
i genuinely don't know
[Music]
baby
[Music]
becky this didn't give me a huge
indication of what it is but the
gameplay and the cars and the
environments now
we've got all these characters that seem
to have different motivations they are
active okay great
thank you it looks like you've got no
actors are not real people they're all
fake
they don't exist the grid series has
always been about delivering gameplay
excellence
and with grid legends you are still
getting that same immersive racing
experience that you know and love
but this time we are taking things up a
notch and we're adding another layer on
top of that
we are really proud of this new story
mode well i do love a good story and
interesting hot shot racing had some
like story mode
kind of stuff i did a stream incredibly
talented shitty gagwa
who plays the wonderful eric in netflix
well i guess um
fifa has done story mode stuff too
extended reality or
xr where if you've been watching
disney's and mandalorian you will have
seen that tech in
action oh this is actually in the game
incredible it's not just in the trailer
well it sounds amazing but this
obviously isn't racing in space right
no we are using this tech to draw you
further into this racing experience
interesting i really want to bring you
deeper into the grid world than ever
before it's also been really great for
our actors because they're acting
against something that's visually
i'm so interested in those those screens
screen screen or motion capture
they are stepping into our grid world
and reacting with it i'm get i want to
read articles about this
i need this tech explained those screens
use the same
tech as uh on a level unreal classic
underdog tale we were putting you
straight into the driver's seat
right in the middle of the grid world
series where you'll be facing off
against the
all dominant raven west team that is a
team that does not like to share the
tarmac
and for the rest of the story well you
just have to wait and see
i didn't think they were bad actors at
cobra i thought they were okay
trailer can you talk about those a
little bit oh yeah there are so many
vehicles we are giving you
big rigs stadium trucks femi on steroids
you're not wrong it is
cars electric cars we are giving you
hyper cars like the aston martin
valkyrie have you seen that car
and we are also giving you multi-class
mixed racing
which means that you can take any of
those cars and put them together on the
same track
whoa i just saw a big rig take out an
open wheeler in the trailer and i i love
it
so is there anything else that you can
tell us about grid legends
we aren't giving too much away there is
a ton
of new stuff for the fans to sink their
teeth into including
been a popular series for a long time i
haven't played grid for a long time
though either
i feel like i don't i used to play a lot
of racing games i [ __ ] loved project
gotham racing
but i don't tend to anymore except that
i will play every
forza horizon release because i find
them so fun
but i love midtown madness as well i
used to really like gran turismo
i just don't really touch them as much
anymore storytelling and extended
i really didn't like the most recent
need for speed that was one of them 2015
maybe it wasn't exciting i don't know
what yeah that i just
loved but then when it went online and
of course
kind of lost me so we're just getting
started we've seen grid legends
now it's time for a different breed of
legend
destiny
makes more sense apex makes more sense
than independent developer bungie's
video game that was cool
100 million players apex is my favorite
battle rail
i still really enjoy it we've got more
modes more maps more platforms for play
and of course more legends
so what's next for april oh bonnet was
really good
crazy taxi hell yeah there was so many
that was so fun ladies and gentlemen
yeah pavloka i didn't like rivals
apex legends emergence
what it's not gonna be a new game is it
change i see it in
everything i see it in a boy
rocked by tragedy transform his
pain and defy reality
who must choose between their new life
and the annihilation of their home i
love bloodhounds
i see it today i have goosebumps
tortured by revenge
embrace hope when love awakens her heart
i see it in me a boy born
under a bad woman he does seem really
cool
into a legend
change is relentless
but that does not mean it cannot be
beautiful such a good accent
this dude [ __ ] for sure that's what i'm
saying he [ __ ] for sure there's no way
he doesn't
oh you haven't played apex great you
should i really love it
[Music]
you must adapt
surrender they're so good at making
these
they're so hype
it's like the overwatch ones were so
good too the shorts
some of those got mad emotional the may
one killed me g'day mate
change comes for us all
[Music]
so i had already seen art of this
character i guess this is his trailer
[Music]
it's very cool
god i really hope i like playing as him
he's so cool
i want to play as the hero who [ __ ]
so what does this mean emergence what
does this mean though
standing here wow slack jawed watching
this because there's so much to unpack
from that trailer so
let's go ahead and meet the man is it
all is there any mode apex
game director chad grenier
so happy to have you here chad thanks
austin happy to be here uh before we get
started and get into it i want to give a
shout out to the amazing development oh
i must have david i must have missed the
pre-show
thanks for the heads up what's up uh if
you love apex it's because of these
amazing developers that are
working hard uh creating legends for us
well big love to the whole baseball team
especially whoever came up with lifeline
because that's
my girl she's also my goal okay love
lifeline for us to talk about
no one's talking about zeer so can you
tell us some more about his abilities
that's right his name's sia yes i
you'll have a heartbeat sensor that will
give you hints as to where an enemy
might be
okay you can use the tactical which
sends out some of those drones out of
your chest
and will actually reveal and track the
enemy's location
the ultimate is really powerful
especially in certain gameplay
situations you can send out hundreds of
micro drones
and create a sphere around an area that
you choose
and all enemies that are moving quickly
to that space are tracked
i love when there's new abilities
interesting that'll be
super helpful for end game always
changing always evolving and whenever
there's a new legend
there's always an interesting shift in
the meta so with those incredible
abilities how do you think that sears
going to change the game
yeah again i mentioned bloodhound also
as a tracker
but unlike bloodhound seer is about very
precise
and lingering information so he's a bit
more of a stealth oriented i feel like
bloodhound has some of that and
you're gonna see i think some
interactions because of that sphere i
mentioned his ultimate
if you're moving quickly through that
space your footsteps are revealed
ah but now if you're walking slowly
it's it's a cool [ __ ] stage it's very
cool
hello rick sanchez welcome we're slowing
him down a bit yeah it sounds like once
the ring gets tight especially you're
gonna have
a lot of new ways to play this game um
but this past season for instance it
felt like apex really moved beyond
battle royale with the introduction of
arenas so what's the reaction i actually
haven't played arenas yet the fan
reaction
has been really great uh people seem to
really like it
i just love the battle royale in apex
i'm really really excited i love it i
finally have a way to play return to it
consistently
it does suck that every time i try to
return to it it has an update though
that is a thing some other things come
in i don't want to just you know talk
about just yet
but we've got a lot planned for arenas
all right fair yeah well
i do know that you guys announced ranked
arenas are coming as well so can you
give us some information on that
yep so we've got one season of arenas
under our belts now
we wanted to make sure that we were
seeing how players were adapting to the
mode
make sure to get the balance right make
sure that the the price and the economy
is correct
and now we'll be introducing the ranked
mode in emergence
so it's a bit of a different ranked
system than we have in
in the battle royale mode so we're
really excited for you to get your hands
on it cool it's
really cool to see apex always doing new
things like for instance
uh leaning into the competitive they do
really like apex i'm maintaining a big
fan
of the algs uh i'm still in australia
roy but currently
one of the lgs um recently sort of
concluded it has been delayed but it's
not an issue
i i will be fine amazing plays in there
many teams were
fighting for the championship in the
last round we hit record numbers so
we're really excited in september to be
kicking off year two of the lgs
and for the first time we're gonna be i
should tune into that i'd probably enjoy
it
and xbox players to compete alongside
the pc players really see who's best
and an all new league forum okay that's
ballsy we'll see how that goes
all right if you say so slash algs well
i am
beyond looking forward to it victor i
agree i think respawn are
fantastic i mean i also really love um
the studio ahead
i'm a huge fan of vincent pellet they're
coming on monday
and emergence drops on august 3rd and
for now
i can show you a finisher of course
please please
that's what she said she said that
this game demands so much of us
but from you he's like iron man
but oh my gosh
that's that's all i need to see okay
you're awesome
but chad thank you so much for being
very good of course
of course and again big shout out to the
whole respawn team
now for the apex fans watching us on
twitch today respawn is hooking you up
with an exclusive jump master gun charm
so make sure you've got your twitch and
ea well i'm too [ __ ] late on i also
watching the show to earn that drop
but that's not the only what about
australians it was 3 a.m
keep an eye out for the hidden letters
what am i supposed to do because at the
end of the show
we'll give you a link where you can
enter that code uh no
new games just yet coded niche well no
grid legends was a new game this is the
first game how i've already forgotten
that
so speaking of originals let's head
across the ocean for some stop motion
and check out a soon to be released ea
original
lost in random is this one from zoink
i think it is and just like that
young austin found himself introducing a
new segment
hello he stole he's doing a really good
job i really like austin doing this
somewhere random
uh okay all right anyway uh it's coming
soon and it looks
really cool austin stopped himself you'd
forgotten
i like this conference i feel like i
usually don't like ea's conferences
i've made videos about them before at
the tribeca film festival so far i'm
into it you tried the line again
more enthusiastically look man i'm
trying to run a whole show
or enthusiastically really selling it
could you just let me intro the segment
thank you
[Laughter]
it was an official tribeca film festival
selection this summer and it's coming
soon
joining us from gothenburg sweden to
tell us more it is zoink games
yeah olaf
the one that i know is klaus um i've met
him a few times
thank you so much for joining us i've
met a few of them they're lovely
very cool to see video games right next
to movies being regarded as they should
be
thank you austin i'm so this is the guy
with the wonderful hair look at him
fabulous so happy about this election
because los angeles is
really inspired by all these movies that
i grew up with and
stop-motion animation and dark fairy
tales and that's like we're always
i'm definitely going to play this game
in video games so i'm so happy yeah
well i i can't wait to see more oh love
of my life
what do you think oh thank you accents
welcome super please to share a first
look at one of our most unique aspects
of lost venom's gameplay dice battle
which is an exciting explosive blend of
real-time action and time stop tactics
where every roll of the dice unleashes
incredible powers out of the head
of your jack-in-the-box buddy dicey well
it
sounds awesome so let's take a look
once so they made uh fae and also
flipping death
again i'm pretty sure both of which are
very good
cruelly separated by an evil
[Music]
hitting some kind of nostalgia boner
within my pants
interesting in this
strange and fascinating world of random
adventure and combat it actually is sort
of making me think of alice madness
returns for some reason
which by the way is also a very good
game if you haven't played it
definitely little nightmares vibes
oh yes i love him already what the [ __ ]
those coins can be traded for cards
it's the dukes in the
abilities interesting and more
all of which come in handy during dice
battle
even uses her slingshot to attack deadly
foes
this looks very unique in terms of
combat used to feed
the strange companion dicey and once
you've been
charged even can rule dicey
and freeze time itself
so it's cards mixed with real-time
combat
interesting
i feel like a lot of this game will
probably be like puzzles
um that was a good one i mean fan
flipping death are both pretty different
um again i hope i'm getting the name of
the flipping desk right i'm pretty sure
yeah
but um faye was very metroidvania
fear i think they pronounced it and play
the odds
and i imagine this will be insane a
chance at saving her sister
they did mix everything together but i
feel like they did a good job
3d magic gathering i could see that
just looks super cool very interesting
alone i already
need to play this game it looks so cool
uh but what can you tell me about these
these combat cards that we're seeing
yeah
cars are just fun part of dice battle
but i love the way they look so i
brought a few examples to show off
oh okay awesome what are we looking at
here then so as you saw
very cool production during combat that
unleashed new powers
that's where your ultimate team cards
are going ladies and gentlemen
into this ticking time bomb right into
this careful so it doesn't blow you up
keep your distance and where's this
hammer of two lets you summon a giant
hammer
which also gives even super strength to
swing it around
offensive maneuvers i like it yugioh
[ __ ] just about offense like we have
also going to feel like you're summoning
which comes things that you then get to
actually use hidden witch and she
provides a bubble shield to protect even
and that's just a taste like there's a
lot of powers at your disposal some
curse
some he'll even or create traps
submarines also work as giant board
games affected by rolling dicey so
you're gonna have to try different
tactics to conquer the queen's giant
mad tabletop themed arenas all right
olav obviously
my next question you know it's coming
when can we play this game
yeah my favorite question boston random
releases on september 10th on pc
console and nintendo i will play this
you can pre-order starting right after
the shows
he's so cute companion of your own will
be available to ea play members as a gun
charm in one of my current favorites
apex so keep an eye out oh that's cute
too well you all heard it here first
and olav thank you so much for joining
us today it has been my absolute
pleasure austin and welcome to random
thanks well there you have it
lost in random is coming i guess using
the cods and the dice is like a
already here and it's bringing that
throwback random
thing they're doing that's right i'm
talking about
knock out city oh yeah knockout city is
a good game
oh oh oh okay i actually never played
chain of memories
i have not seen anything lord bugbug uh
regarding this at all i have stayed off
twitter i had gone once and then was
like oh i need to leave summer
i have not had anything spoiled for me
but based on people asking
from villain studios in new york i'm now
suspecting
thanks austin something good grateful to
our community for a massive response to
knockout
city with millions of new brawlers
hundreds of thousands of crews
and nearly a billion kos landed your
response has really been
a knockout as an indie team dedicated
to yourself creative risks having all of
you i think knockout city is really fun
i am we've made played several hours of
it
but only in one setting i haven't
retired but i did enjoy what i played i
don't i don't feel compelled to play
multiple new features
but um that keep the game fresh and
exciting definitely would if anyone
asked me i'd be like totally game's fun
we're on that promise on behalf of the
whole villain studios team
it's my absolute thrill to present
knockout city
season two fight at the movies that was
quick
two months of chaos where
mayhem rules the streets is anyone
strong enough
to stop the unstoppable it's psychonauts
a world where one hero rises to meet
instant regret
a world where lovers chase their
passions
and feel the burn
a world where terror lurks high
above
they said it was movies themed is it
suppose oh
okay because it's like stages
dodge roll supremacy go [ __ ] yourself
battle it out in a child's bedroom i see
yeah it's because it kind of looks like
sets
is the idea bring your moves to the
movie
it'd be cool if they i think that's
godzilla i guess that's anything
coming um if they did
oh man that voice is murder yeah please
stop
if they did crossovers with other ea
properties would be neat it's july
27th we'll see you in the movie
next week it's showtime
cool you saw we got new skins we got a
new ball
knockout city baby season two arrives
july
27th and remember you can play for free
up to street rank 25 so get in
you might come across me and my crew
we're called that baseline you won't
beat us because we're really good
but you'll have fun and right now it's
available on
all platforms with cross play so if you
haven't yet go ahead get in there and
give it a whirl
okay i if i hadn't now i would austin
the enthusiasm that you have been
waiting for
it's fifa isn't it
it's battlefield okay i was waiting for
that actually in the trailers
you've read the hot takes and you
already know that battlefield is back
baby
you hear me it's back battlefield is
back man it's a bad outfield
i can't wait to wing suit surfer all
right i don't know about all this
it didn't really go anywhere dude
as stoked as i am but first
for those who haven't been paying
attention here's what you've been
missing out on
that's the coolest thing i've ever seen
that's very cool i just got goosebumps
again
where are these people getting like
three friends to watch conferences or
[ __ ] with them
for recording how are you finding these
friends that you have
we hope you're thrilled with what you've
seen so how does that work
but this is just the beginning we have
so
much more to show you battlefield 2042
is built up by three epic experiences
firstly of course all that warfare that
we showed you earlier
secondly hazard zone that will show off
later this year
and now a new community driven
experience that we're happy to share
with you
today built by our old friends over at
triple effect
formerly dice delay it's an experience
designed from community feedback
it's an experience we've dreamt about
building for over a decade
so let's have a look
god that's so [ __ ] good at editing
trailers man
god damn the music
sick
thank you i missed you have it donated i
also do really want to watch this
let me check your name real quick thank
you john i appreciate that so much i
love him
little cutie
god battlefield's so much fun it really
is back
[Music]
as you do
i'm very excited about these the wing
suits
gonna be dope
yeah this shit's gonna be [ __ ]
ridiculous i hope this game runs
very good that is what i expected seeing
all of those uh
all of them spawn in from the jump
and that defibrillator was like
always a huge hit that's why they
highlighted it so much
incredible there's so many crazy things
happening in this trailer we got knives
versus defibrillators we got soldiers
from every year
it would be very good it would be very
good bring on an expert here to help us
out is the
general manager of ripple effect we've
got christian grass
welcome christian hey austin thanks for
having me super excited to be here of
course thank you for being here
now that trailer absolutely it's
ridiculous like what
it's all very good so what you just saw
was the battlefield portal it's a new
community
lesbians with the trailers the freedom
write their own rules
and shape their own battlefield you can
mix and match content from battlefield
1942
that company too [ __ ] love both of
them
that's what gets me it's like i feel
like they're playing into the nostalgia
bonus of
battlefield 1942 and vietnam were the
first two games ever played online but
bad company too is
i [ __ ] love that game this is so sick
incredible team and oh
and this is your squad yes i also like
that they're doing that
effect team and they deserve all the
credit in the world for creating this
great experience we've had so much fun
bringing back some of the most beloved
vehicles
gadgets weapons and maps from past
titles
well thank you all very good to this
amazing team
and everyone who's made battlefield
2042. christian cross is my favorite
beloved man very good tony yes eureka
harbor
yes el alamein yes el alamein is also
included it's actually my all-time
favorite map
plus we have no shark canal battle of
the bulge
and valparaiso it's a really good idea
seven of the new epic scale maps already
announced for 2042
they're also playable in portal damn
dude that's sick it's more than just
maps right
absolutely portal is a chance for the
community to drive the platform there's
a whole slate
of customization options and even an
advanced logic editor for you to play
around with
previously only available to us on the
development team
so yeah that's neat it's packed with a
ton of crazy moments
so i'm curious how wild can we actually
get with portal
you can get pretty wild yeah i'm good
thank you tony
having a great time enjoying this
conference australia is good
okay well australia is actually a [ __ ]
show right now but
i'm good being in australia absolutely
okay uh what about shoddy snipes but but
not just regular shoddy snipes like
like like a gun game with a whole bunch
of shoddy snipes from all throughout
history
that is a very specific idea there
austin but yes actually you can
baton three for three bring it home can
i play
as a penguin with a flamethrower a
penguin with a flamethrower yeah
no i mean look there are some limits
it's not a level editor you can't edit
the maps themselves
and no you can't play as a penguin with
a fame thrower all right that's that's
fine
it's fine i have to ask there's going to
be a lot of good content that'll come
out of this too
to play around oh yes it's going to be
dubsteps are pretty deep very important
to working with the community to build
out this suite of tools and content as
the game evolves
we want this experience i don't know
1942 just
immediately just gets me right in the
heart the future of battlefield 2042
set yourself up for that the community
is going to have a field day with this
i really hope players will embrace
portal uh that's they will they will
you done did it it's gonna be good a
sneak peek to a few members of the
community
to see what they could come up with oh i
wasn't planning to watch the olympic
opening ceremony well that's fine that's
what time is it let's check it out
it's soon isn't it two teams and two
vips
two [ __ ] teams this is vip fiesta
by courage it's the us factions of
battlefield 3 and bad company 2
facing off on erica harbour with 24
players
and random loadouts it is going to be so
sick
this is going to be so much fun oh my
god
all bring the power of 2042 to caspian
border
and take on the forces of 1942 this
is quality versus quantity by gabitron
that's an interesting one oh man i'm
stoked man this this can be [ __ ] done
from 2042 are taking on 32 players from
1942
uh tony yeah it is 8 p.m right now 802.
it's in an hour i could watch it destroy
those mcoms
but do it before your tickets are up
you're not getting them back
unless you clear the sector
not enough memes fine set up on orbital
for the fight of your lives
with robot man by redacted
all right 20 duck sized eod all right
one horse-sized t-91 settle your
battlefield debates on who wins what
my god yes i love it
come on dude i really do this looks so
much fun
but i need to know just pretend like the
cameras aren't here just mean you
who's redacted can't tell you that sorry
but what i can tell you is that we're so
excited for the players
to create or simply discover their
favorite new way to play it's gonna be a
good time i'm gonna do a bunch of
streams
explore and try out the thousands of
experiences
our community it's going to get
ridiculous it's going to be awesome
get our hands on portable launch right
yes florida will be
cool with it at launch day one along
with a bunch of pre-made modes for you
to try right away
okay this is this is fantastic right
christian before you go
what's the c then i have all of this
straight i'm covering it with my face
but
c just showed up behind us oh that's the
game codes that's right
battlefield 1942 bad company and
battlefield
very good games and all that can be
sliced into the played a lot less of
three and then we
still have hazard zone coming later this
year
yes that's exactly what i'm telling you
austin if you've always been a fan or if
you've never played
battlefield before we want battlefield
2042 to be the ultimate battlefield
experience
christian just it's good
it's good my pleasure austin i'll see
you on the battlefield
oh thank you for that adam oh i could i
could throw on some channel seven with
my mom
i could do that i don't think we're done
just yet
we're gonna leave you with one more
surprise first though you remember that
secret code
i hope you were paying attention because
all the letters have been revealed so
the link to enter in just a second oh
yeah okay for now
come with me
i hope you've enjoyed the show as well
so do they already do the fifa stream
my name is austin creed and our last
reveal is somewhere
in there
but you know what i'm nervous
is this gonna be dead space
you're joking please don't be
what
never in a million [ __ ] years did i
think
it could be something else it could be
something else oh my god it's dead space
what kidding me
what is it is it a new game
holy [ __ ] my boy
oh this is uh remastered it's dead space
one
oh i'm totally [ __ ] cool with that
i'll take that
and also if they remaster video games it
means that they're planning on making a
new video game
that's what that means holy
[ __ ] what
i
i can't believe they gave me so many
things that i wanted
ea oh my god
it's a remake that's what i figured
that makes perfect sense
i didn't see the leak if it was leaked
yes sorry i meant to say the word remake
of course it's not a remaster it looks
too good i definitely meant to see re
say remake i definitely knew it was a
remake that it doesn't look like a
remaster it's way too good
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] that looks so
good oh my god and i love that game and
it's also a cool thing about remakes too
is that uh they feel pretty different a
lot of the time
it's like having an and that game still
holds up i was just playing dead space
last year
the first game still holds up too
holy [ __ ] man that's that's very good
news the news is very good
i'm also very glad that i didn't get it
spoiled for me
very good aaron oh so hi holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] it's ea motive no way
i have friends on that team oh man
they're so good at sound design too
and like that's the thing about dead
space
that gets you
i can't believe that usually my reaction
to ea conferences is like i guess i'll
watch it i don't know whatever and a lot
of them i find boring and i just got
some of the best battlefield content
that i've ever seen in [ __ ] years
a game from zoink that looks sick and
a new ish dead space
i wasn't prepared for this i didn't
expect this at all
holy [ __ ]
oh my god sarcasm yes dead space is
super scary
absolutely yes dead space is
some real spooky [ __ ] it's it's
i think the first one especially is
really scary again because of the sound
design also love to
i mean i also enjoyed three three is
just a different game it's definitely a
lot less scary
um and that's because they tried to make
it more accessible and it's definitely
an issue in the games industry where i
was like there's no way that they do
anything to do with dead space ever
again i've been so
sure of that because
i guess it's reframed recently but
horror games
ea has viewed as being less accessible
that's part of why they shut down
visceral from
what i've been told they're like people
don't play horror games
they're too scary you're automatically
cutting up so much of the audience
because people are uncomfortable because
they're afraid
but resident evil doing so well
i feel like disproves all of that [ __ ]
and now we get dead space and the fact
that we're getting a dead space remaster
sorry i keep saying the wrong word i
mean remake i know that i mean remake i
keep saying remastered
whatever fact that we're getting a dead
space remake
often means that there is new content
from that franchise coming
meaning that maybe we'll get a four and
if this is spooky as [ __ ] and it sells
well
then they make four spookiest [ __ ] as
well rather than going the three out
where it was like
a bit more about weapon mods which i
still found really fun it wasn't i
didn't find that game terribly scary
that's my rant yeah thank you to
everybody on the internet for not
spoiling this for me today
my god strongly agree resident evil 7
had a big impact but so did re2
re 3 remakes and re-8 selling so well
has totally led to this like
oh my gosh i'm so happy
i know that i look sad and shocked my
face is
but the inside of me
i feel like i need to like go for a walk
it's like i have to process everything
that happened in this conference
and i just didn't expect it and i
thought austin was great and
holy [ __ ] uh when's the new podcast
episode coming to spotify now is not the
time uh episode
70 of play witch listen will be up
probably like 7 a.m pacific time i'll
publish it
69 got stuck i reached out to them for
help it's not on google play and spotify
it's like stuck on pending i reached out
to them for help hopefully they can fix
it i still don't know why
anyway wow i'm very happy about this i'm
such a big horror fan
um and if there's anything that i've
learned from
my time my what nine months now working
in game dev has it been longer than that
it has is that i think that one day i
will end up making a horror game because
i always have these
ideas that i'm like but what if
what if like i ah
great news thank you x sensei
my gosh um
those are my main takeaways i do kind of
feel like i need a cigarette promise and
i don't smoke i have asthma it would
kill me
but it's like when you've had really
good sex and you go take a cigarette the
way they frame that in movies that's how
i feel right now
i need to just like in a bed
to like pipe down a bit holy [ __ ]
oh there's an ign interview
cool and i also have said before uh
that i think that on youtube i will do
playthroughs of um horror games
exclusively
i will totally do dead space i'll keep
doing resident evils as they come
because i imagine they're going to keep
making those based on the successes yeah
i'll do dead space for sure
oh my god very good
wow
[Laughter]
um thank you guys so much for joining me
for this
yeah absolutely vida i agree out of
nowhere
uh ea play ended up being awesome
that was unexpectedly very very fun
all right thank you guys so much for
watching i will see you all
next time bye